Welcome back.
I'm sorry.
I actually had to take a
five-second pause because
something came up, but
let me continue.
Problem number 10.
So let's see, they say that
this is x degrees.
So there's a formula for the
angles inside of a polygon,
but what I'm going to do is
derive it for you, because
frankly, on an exam you can--
well, later in life, it's very
easy to forget everything.
So what I do is, we know that
all of the angles are
congruent, right?
So if we know that this is--
let's call this angle y, then
this angle is going to be y,
this angle going to be y, that
is y, that's y, that's y, that's
y, that's y, that's y,
that's y, right?
All of these angles
are the same.
And what do we know about
these angles here?
Let's called these
z, z, z, z, z.
There are five of these z angles
and what are they going
to add up to be?
Well, they go around
in a circle, right?
So these five z angles
are going to have to
add up to 360 degrees.
So we could say 5z is equal
to 360 degrees.
z is equal to-- let's see, 5
goes into 360, 7, 35, 10, 72.
So z is equal to 72 degrees.
So each of these z's
is 72 degrees.
That angle of 72 degrees,
what are the y's?
Well, y plus y plus z has
to be 180, right?
So you have y plus y plus 72
is equal to 180 degrees.
2y plus 72 is equal to 180.
2y is equal to what?
108.
And actually we could
solve for y.
y is 54.
But really we just want
to know what 2y is
because look at this.
We're trying to solve for x.
x plus 2y is 180, right?
How did I get that?
x is supplementary
with y and y.
This is 2y right here and
altogether they are
supplementary.
So that's where I get
x plus 2y is 180.
We know what 2y is.
It's 108.
x plus 108 is equal to 180.
x is equal to-- and actually,
it's interesting. x is going
to be equal to z, right?
x is 72 degrees.
And that is choice C.
And that actually is
interesting that x
is the same as z.
And actually, when you think
about it, it makes sense
because y plus y plus z is 180,
and here, y plus y plus x
has to be 180.
So x is going to
be equal to z.
You say there are 360 degrees
in the circle.
Divide by the number of z's
there are, one, two, three,
four, five, you get 72.
Next problem.
Problem 11.
The length of a drawing of a
tool is 3/8 of the length of
the actual tool.
OK, if the length of the drawing
of the tool is 6
inches, what is the length in
inches of the actual tool?
OK, 6 inches is equal to 3/8
times the actual tool.
Let's multiply both sides
of this equation by the
reciprocal of this right here.
So let's say 8/3 times 6 is
equal to 8/3 times 3/8a.
This, of course, cancels out.
That's why I multiplied
by the reciprocal.
And this becomes a 2,
this becomes a 1.
8 times 2 is 16.
So the actual tool
is 16 inches.
And that's choice C.
Next problem.
Problem 12.
I might have space
to do it here.
If x plus 3/2 is an integer-- so
they're saying x plus 3 is
divisible by 2, right?
Because in order for this to be
an integer-- and so what do
we know about x?
Well, x plus 3 has to be
even number, right?
Because it's divisible by 2.
So that must mean that x has
to be an odd number.
How do I know that?
So I know that x
plus 3 is even.
If x plus 3 is even, then
I know that x is odd.
Why is that?
Because 3 is odd.
The only way, if I had one
number plus an odd and I get
an even, this number has
to be odd as well.
2 odds added together equal
an even, right?
For example, 5 plus 3 is
8, or 11 plus 3 is 14.
So an odd plus an
odd is an even.
So x has to be odd.
So when we look at the choices,
we have choice E.
x is an odd integer.
That's the only thing that we
can really assume based on
this, and that's because x
plus 3 has to be even.
And anything plus an odd and
you get an even, that thing
you added to the odd has
to be odd as well.
And you can try it
out with numbers.
Next problem.
Problem 13.
All right.
In the x, y plane above, points
q and s are the centers
of the circle.
Which are tangent
to the x-axis?
Let me see if I can draw this.
So this is the y-axis.
This is the x-axis.
And now they draw a
couple of circles.
A small one and a big one.
Let's see if I can draw it.
The small circle looks
something like that.
And the big circle doesn't
touch the small circle.
So the big circle looks
something like that.
Fair enough.
Let's see, this is point Q.
This is point S and those
are the centers.
And they tell us that this point
right here is 3 comma 6,
and this point up here
is 11 comma 10.
And what else?
This is point R.
this is point P, QS, oh, and
then one last thing, I'm
drawing this line here
and a line here.
In both cases, they say this
is a perpendicular.
Let's do the problem.
In the x, y plane above, points
Q and S are the centers
of the circle, which are tangent
to the x-axis, right?
They just barely touch the
x-axis right here.
That's the x-axis.
What is the slope of line QS?
So what is the slope
of this line?
Line QS?
And it could go further out like
that, go further in this
direction like that.
So we really just have
to figure out the
coordinates Q and S.
So Q is the center of this, so
it's tangent to the x-axis.
This entire diameter has what?
Has height what?
Height 6.
So this the point 3.
This is 3, 6, so what's
this Q going to be?
The x is definitely going to
still be 3 and the y is going
to be halfway to
this top point.
Well, what's halfway to 6?
3.
Similarly, this is point 11
comma 10, so the x-coordinate
is 11 and this y-coordinate
is to 10.
So what's the coordinate
of S going to be?
The x-coordinate is, of course,
still going to be 11.
And the y-coordinate is going
to be halfway to 10.
What's halfway to 10?
It's 5.
So what's the slope?
Slope is change in y
over change in x.
So let's take the y's.
It's 5 minus 3 over
11 minus 3.
That equals 2/9.
No, sorry, 2/8.
I always mess up
on that stuff.
11 minus 3 is 8.
So 2/8 and that equals 1/4.
And that is choice D.
I'll see you in the
next video.